salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors
alors aujourd'hui puisqu'il fait part au
dehors on a décidé de vous faire une
vidéo un peu spéciale je te laisse
expliquer le concept alors je lui
explique que le concept regarde
énormément de chaîne youtube qui font de
la pêche à leyment donc que ce soit à
l'étranger donc aux états unis en russie
et etc et on s'est dit qu'il y avait
parfois des vidéos qui passait inaperçu
en france et qui avait pourtant un
potentiel énorme et des découvertes
énorme ou même des péripéties et n'avait
donc ce que j'ai dit c'est que vous avez
vous sélectionné trois vidéos donc voilà
au programme pour aujourd'hui trois
vidéos tournées les 3 aux etats unis son
ouïe et en 2021 ce sont des vidéos
récentes voilà donc des vidéos récentes
ce qu'on va faire c'est quand les
vallées regarder ensemble et on va aller
commenté vous allez voir qu'il se passe
pas mal de choses intéressantes on va
commencer par la première ouais si
d'accord et en plus comme ça tous ceux
qui comprennent pas l'anglais c'est bon
vous c'est une tradition à ça on va les
expliquer aux militants et vous pourrez
toujours aller voir les chaînes qui
seront en description si vous voulez
voir les vidéos en complet ouais on va
commencer par danny way dany dit
pourrait donc c'est un pêcheur éléments
qui est dans un spot dans ligne via
nager entre un péché aliments dans les
canaux au début il trouve beaucoup de
petits morceaux de ferraille
des choses comme ça
et d'un coup il va tomber sur un vivier
à fond donc voilà on voulait spectre et
non regardez cette belle découverte
super découverte de dany donc bien sûr
quand on trouve une arme empêche
aliments qu'ils aient fait un bon pas on
appelle la police donc c'est ce qui fait
donc voila tout se passe bien puisque il
est temps la police bon là on ne le
paraît assez dia et mérite une attention
il a des gants il appose dans sa voiture
sans trop la manipuler donc là ce qu'il
faut faire général quand on travaille là
on peut le voir ici des postes en armes
tout va bien on a fait qu'il a dans la
police et continuer à pêcher le premier
policier arrive ouais donc on s'en sort
bien c'est sympa en tenons à l'oreille
il veut pas trouvé ce film et non c'est
sûr il va pas de borne à part ça c'est
son droit donc tout va bien il récupère
larmes ouais il a regardé bien sûr
différente à sion regarder les
manipulations dissidents varié il fait
très attention aux nues aux états unis
on rigole pas avec ça non c'est sûr on
va appeler l'équipe de ncis et et après
bon ce qui est un peu étrange c'est que
les policiers restent autour et il y en
a même certains qui viennent
s'intéresser à la pêche à aimants qui
font quelques lancers donc voilà
ouailles et policiers dont qui prend les
membres drôle de façon de jeter son
aimant oui c'est parce qu'on recommande
d' ne reproduisez pas ça mais c'est
quand même bizarre toutes ces voitures
de police carif pour moi une découverte
d'armes tu vois à la suite d'une voiture
ouais ouais ouais au blizzard est un peu
étrange 4 commence à sentir pas
seulement pendant ce temps dany et ses
collègues qui continuent à pêcher à
leyment ils sortent des vélos beaucoup
de vélo étrangement un petit fauteuil
roulant dont un petit peu impacté roll
alors mme mignon correspondait en
arrière
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que ça
arrive en france aussi ouais quand on
trouve une arme ou même quand on appelle
la police pour je ne sais quelle raison
on prend notre identité
c'est un petit peu le principal problème
auquel va être confronté notre bon danny
way c'est qu'il va donner son nom voilà
et là ça va commencer à sentir le roussi
mail à elie comprenait pas pourquoi
l'upa et comprend pas et d'accous
lacourte
il s'est arrêté donc il se fait arrêter
par le policier qu'il a fait tester leur
personnellement allé 20 minutes avant il
met carrément les menottes voilà
résister aux belles vidéos ben c'est
aussi pour ça que cette vidéo un buzz t
600 millions alors qu'elle a moins d'un
mois c'est un typique mort parce que il
a réussi à se retrouver sans sa propre
prestation sur sa chaîne youtube et
couteaux sympa et on va on va recevoir 1
créé un petit peu plus tard on voit ses
amis donc qui ne me comprennent pas
forcément non et qui justement récupère
la caméra nous expliquez nous ce qui se
passe youtube heures pour leur demander
de l'argent un groupe et il la caution
alors pourquoi vous à dire pourquoi est
ce qui se fait arrêter alors que c'est
lui même qui a appelé la police pour
leur remettre l'arbre oui bah en fait
c'est tout simple c'est que dany était
recherché par la police et bien voilà il
était il était recherché moi j'étais pas
au courant non j'étais recherché ouais
je t'es même pas en courant
et
donc il nous explique après en fait ce
qui s'est passé ouais il nous a expliqué
tout ça en descriptions en fait il était
en vacances en 2019 en californie et
dans l'état et l'état de californie à
los angeles angeles il était à los
angeles en vacances quand il a assisté à
bon après c'est un petit peu flou mais
il aurait assisté à une sorte de
kidnapping d'une petite fille et ce
serait en fait interposés donc on a
craint sait pas vraiment si c'est
vraiment un kidnapping ou pas mais en
gros se serait interposé en ayant vu une
situation dans le nord voilà et et la
personne en fait aurait porté plainte
donc l'agresseur en fête aurait porté
plainte contre lui dans l'état de
californie dont il ya deux ans et depuis
ce jour une à un mandat d'arrêt émis par
l'état californien sur la tête et ben
voilà en checkant son nom dans les bases
de données ils ont ils ont choppé le bon
ami et il a quand même fait comme
toujours quoi 22 jours de prison donc
c'est cher payé la vache à lait
heureusement cette histoire finit bien
puisque dany a pris un avocat
à mon sens que tu n'auras
chichester el sol où wade a fini par
être libéré et en plus la personne qui
avait porté plainte contre lui a été
inquiété semble que cette personne et
même recherché actuellement oui c'est
quand même tapé 20 jours de prison oui
mais non c'est triste elle galère pour
lui mais au final ils avaient sûrement
raison comme composent maintenant c'est
passé à la deuxième vidéo à notre
sélection donc voilà travail est bien
plus belle pour cette deuxième vidéo se
retrouve toujours aux états unis à saint
louis dans le missouri avec daf of
history donc c'est un pêcheur aimant
plongeurs mais cette fois ci fait ce
qu'on appelle le mug larkin dont qui
marche tout simplement dans le lit de la
rivière pour voir ce qu'il peut trouver
voilà donc le mode la fing c'est une
pratique qui existe depuis le 19e siècle
on a vu les populations pauvres surtout
londonienne qui cherchait dans la vase à
récupérer des choses ça donc ici en fait
ils descendent d'un redoux qui paraît en
apparence tranquille parce que voilà sur
le palais ce qu'ils font dire qu'il
paraît pas énorme
plein de petites choses mais surtout un
sac que 7 de femmes qui commencent à
ouvrir cinq suivants de découverte en
découverte dans ce set la
voilà dans un premier temps ils ont une
espèce de tee shirt bleu bien enroulé
ensuite les surprises vont continuer
dans cette affaire
commence par sortir des couteaux aurait
plein couteaux des coûts tout lancé me
semblerait donc c'est un peu bizarre il
est vrai deux manches nom étrange ouais
c'est le couteau vous prenez comme ça
chaque fois qu il ya pas mal d'heures et
puis des billets elias donc du coup
c'est des dollars mais plutôt sympa
ouais et bonne anecdote à savoir c'est
qu'en france peu importe l'état du bien
tant qu'on peut lire le numéro
la banque va pouvoir vous les échanger
contre des neuf
nous ça nous est jamais arrivé mais
timidement si vous trouvez un coffre
fort avec à l'intérieur d'un des billets
et qui sont encore à peu près lisible
ouais il suffit de les faire sécher et
de les échanger gratuitement contre des
billets tout leur art est plutôt
intéressant j'espère qu'on peut le faire
aussi aux états unis
si
non parce que le problème c'est qu'il y
avait également une arme à feu voilà un
petit piste des pistolets qui ressemble
aussi à un pistolet de fans donc c'est
même possible que ce sac appartenait
tout simplement à une femme oui oui
parce que c'est vrai qu'on est quand
même aux états unis donc avoir une arme
à feu ouais c'est pas non plus quelque
chose de choquant c'est possible je sais
pas quel est le cas dans le missouri
n'est peut-être c'est bizarre dans le
sens où si c'était un vol de sac y
aurait pas les billets ouais non c'est
étonnant donc c'est plutôt étonnant et
c'est pour ça qu'ils s'appellent
directement la police et qu'ils essaient
de comprendre d'où vient ce sac il ya
donc remettre leur découverte à la
police et ça le rend bien sûr super
vidéo surtout super retrouvailles qu'on
a d'avoir laissé un peu les trois en un
ce qui est plutôt rare empêcha léman
alors on oublie souvent mais il n'y a
pas forcément besoin d'éléments pour
faire des trouvailles en les guerres il
suffit parfois de marché dans le lit de
la rivière tout simplement en faisant
attention bien entendu aux crues et pour
le coup je sais pas si c'est un coup de
chance ou pas mais ils n'étaient pas
recherchés et données ne sont pas faits
arrêter non
façon à la vidéo numéro 3 2 se
retrouvent toujours avec take up history
qui cette fois est avec un autre
youtuber qui lui est d'habitude plus
spécialisés dans la recherche de
personnes disparues dans les voitures
donc gros youtuber américain harris
paris with love ouais exploring would
not pour cette découverte ont calé en
deux parties les deux youtuber ont tous
les deux trouvé les éléments reliés ben
on commence par le premier regarder
donc ça c'est un grand classique
normalement détruits de rivière un
pistolet voilà le pistolet ils savent
que ce modèle là peut-être qu'ils
peuvent déjà voir que c'est un modèle
particulier way 9 mm d'après ce qu'ils
font d'art et qui par la police alors la
police notamment d'autres aux etats-unis
aussi mais oui et c'est plus la deuxième
découverte qui nous intéresse puisque
c'est la plus
surprenante et fallait alors regardez
ils ont trouvé cette boîte permet
des anglais sur des styles et ouvrir la
boîte qui remplit
toujours un moment émouvant pour une
boîte comme ça et quand c'est parce qu'à
l'intérieur elle a commis 10 et youtuber
explose ne s'attendait à trouver encore
des bijoux des choses comme ça à quoi le
classique et reste pas
du tout
baj il identifie tout de suite donc ce
qui ressemble à un badge de police mots
bien sûr les formes américaines donc
avec le cuir et la signe au milieu
des
choses donc il s'agit d'un bal du fph
donc les agents de l'air force en plus
donc de l'armée de l'air américaine donc
c'est en gros c'est un agent secret un
carrément c'est vraiment un badge
d'agent secret il trouvait gare
également la carte d'agent bien sûr il a
tout flouté parce qu'il veut pas vendre
ennuis je pense que là mais c'est ça
regardez le montre encore plus la carte
ici on veut vraiment que c'est un agent
spécial
c'est rigole pas du tout non et
exploring weasley goody que bp ferait
prendre aucun risque donc il va fêter le
plus possible et il va vite contacté les
autorités pour leur médecin et la diane
intérêts là en tout cas c'est plutôt
incroyable comme découverte et la salle
un peu si qu'on se demande comment c'est
possible si ça a été volé ou c'est
justement
l'agent qui dut s'en débarrasser pour
pas être inquiété et en fait non puisque
du coup il appelle les autorités pour
leur remettre le match
ils ont été volés oui ils ont été volés
donc le badge et datés de 1997
donc c'était sûrement quelqu'un qui
gardait son badge ses nuits il
cambriolait et les gens du ca il en prit
et j'imagine que c'était éviter 6 heures
café avec ça il risqué quand même gros
parce que vous les voulez vous utilisez
un belge d'agents du fbi à
paris c'était le cambrioleur mais faut
pas déconner non plus lorsque surtout
aux etats-unis c'est un coup à faire pas
mal d'années de prison à oui mais oui je
vais quand on voit qu'on fait vingt
jours
encore une fois ça va marquer ça eh bien
écoutez on espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu voilà ces trois vidéos vous en plus
d'ailleurs mais quand vous a fait
découvrir des chaînes youtube sympa
ouais c'est ça nous c'était un plaisir
de regarder ça avec vous et de vous
montrer un petit peu ce qui se fait à
l'étranger lui même même si vous parlez
pas anglais je trouve que ça se regarde
très bien dans tous les cas nous ce
qu'on va faire c'est que si ce format
vous plaît on en fera date on va essayer
d'aller un petit peu dans d'autres pays
bref d'aller voir ce qui se passe en
russie et en europe de l'est alors ils
font des belles découvertes c'est clair
il faut juste trouver les vidéos faire
ça et on se dit ah la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle vidéo de pêche
aliments cette fois ci ouais ouais mais
tu es un commentaire si ça vous a plu au
ciné cité n'hésitez pas à nous dire
laquelle des trois vidéos vous avez
préféré derrière et aussi à nous dire
pourquoi oui vraiment comme un aimant
comme un aimant comme un aimant
remaniement comme un aimant comme un
aimant comme un aimant